les sondages les plus pessimistes la
situer largement à la traîne du
rassemblement national 20 heures hier
soir marie-guite dufay apprend qu'elle
sort en tête la présidente sortante
reviens de loin quand je pense que j'ai
été crédité de ce c + 12 ou 13% où on
m'a posé des questions sur qu'est ce que
je faisais dans ce scrutin
eh bien je vois que nous avons commencé
à peser mais que combat n'est pas
terminé le combat passera-t-il par une
alliance avec le candidat de la
république en marche
la réponse ne va pas tarder je lance un
appel à toute la gauche au sein
d'anciens socialistes
il est un peu de gauche encore non pas
du tout je pense je parle demain samedi
ça veut dire que ce soit vous estimez
avec la l'union de la gauche si vous y
arrivez que vous pouvez remporter cette
élection sans la république embarras
bruit absolument les maquereaux nist
pensaient détenir les clés du second
tour
le camouflet de la présidente scène très
vite le trouble moi j'ai le coeur à
gauche comme on sait que ge a parlé je
viens de la gauche
souvenez vous quand même comme
l'araignée du fait il m'a semblé que je
n'avais pas mal aidé à être élu il ya
cinq ans à la région pour gagner voilà
bon mais j'attends pas de reconnaissance
du tout ni de retour
c'est à elle maintenant qu'à la main si
elle ne veut pas bon on en tirera les
conséquences
marie-guite dufay n'en fait pas mystère
elle tend la main aux écologistes avec
plus de 10% des voix stéphanie modde
veut peser dans le rapport de force
interne à la gauche est les délais sont
très courts
donc bien sûr c'est ce samedi que tout
va se décider puisque vous demander on
demande à ce qu'on puisse avoir un
projet commun pour la bourgogne franche
comté avec un projet fort écologiste et
solidaire ancré à gauche
première discussion avec les échos nos
portes fermées il y a cinq ans les
négociations avaient pour cadre la
mairie de dijon chez françois rebsamen
cette fois ci c'est dans un hôtel privé
le signe d'une émancipation
les discussions ont duré jusqu'à 6h ce
matin l'alliance rose et verte n'a rien
d'un long fleuve tranquille
[Musique]